juin 1988 une porte vers l'indépendance
s'en trouvera pour la nouvelle calédonie
c'est le fruit d'une signature
historique d'un dialogue entre pro et
anti indépendance les accords de
matignon
il marque la fin d'un cycle de violences
une page nouvelle va pouvoir s'écrire
non par les armes mais par le dialogue
par la tolérance par le travail par la
volonté retour deux mois en arrière
avant cette signature la question de
l'indépendance ne cesse de gonfler elle
oppose deux camps d'un côté les
indépendantistes du fln ks le front de
libération nationale kanak et socialiste
de l'autre le rpcr le rassemblement pour
la calédonie dans la république
le conflit bascule le 22 avril 1988
sur l'île d'ouvéa un commando
indépendantiste du fln k s attaquent la
principale gendarmerie trois morts trois
gendarmes abattus à l'armé blanche des
machettes des sabres la nouvelle a
ébranlé le territoire dinan final quatre
gendarmes tués le commando prend 27
gendarmes en otage et se réfugier dans
une grotte il faut six jours pour
localiser la cachette le 5 mai 1988
l'assaut est donné 19 indépendantistes
et deux militaires sont tués
quelques jours après le drame michel
rocard fraîchement nommé premier
ministre se rend à nouméa
sous son égide indépendantistes et
loyalistes se mette enfin autour d'une
table
le rpcr le fln qu'ils trouvent un accord
au bout de trois jours les accords de
matignon sont signés il pose les jalons
d'un référendum en nouvelle calédonie
qui pourrait trouver son issue ce week
end
[Musique]